[Musique]
salut à tous vous êtes bien sur
envergure Underdogs le retour épisode 2
je suis ce soir accompagné de HUG que
vous connaissz sur twitch tous les
vendredis sur la chaîne envergure
salut salut j'espère que tout le monde
va bien je suis très content d'être avec
vous again and again
et pour compliquer pour compliquer pour
compléter le
trio on a Julien j'ai compris le message
pierre j'ai compris le message je ESS
c'est le message la tu
veux Julien comment comment vas-tu
très très bien très content d'être avec
vous de ça fait très plaisir mais
pareillement ça nous rappelle qu'on
vieillit aussi parce que on avait
commencé ces épisodes il y a quelques
temps et là on les reprend donc on est
aussi très content de de relancer ça
j'espère que ça vous fait plaisir aussi
à vous bien évidemment c'est un peu le
but donc voilà ce soir nous allons
parler de deux nouveaux joueurs on av
évoqué Calif battle et Brandon Carson
lors du premier épisode je vous propose
que nous ons encore du côté de
l'arcena avec HUG qui va nous parler de
Tron Mark yes on va parler de trayon
Mark qui est un super joueur de basket
ça c'est plutôt important pour espérer
avoir un podcast sur envergure Tron Mark
pour le présenter moi je vous propose
maintenant l'inévitable j'ai envie de
dire 94 pied avec HUG je vais vous
proposer trois
anecdotes une seule est vraie attention
c'est vraiment pas évident de trouver et
deux du coup sont fausses pour les les
plus matau d'entre vous première
anecdote publque messieur très bonne
marque avait toujours de très bonnes
notes à l'école celle-là c'est pour les
anglophones c'est pour les anglophone
ouis deuxième anecdote alors
contrairement à ce que son prénom laisse
sous-entendre d'ailleurs ça l'énerve
beaucoup il préfère clairement le bus
ouais ouais je suis il est 22h50 les
gars je depuis 5h30 je fais ce que je
peux je fais ce que je peux trisème
anecdote c'est un arrière d'AM 96 pour
81 kg qui est né dans le Texas et qui a
fait déjà plusieurs saisons 4 saisons NC
sa 4e TR à Houston et une àa alors à
votre avis réfléchissez bien ne vous
trompez pas laquelle est
vrai alors moi cette semaine je choisis
la
de c'est possiblement une bonne réponse
c'est possiblement une bonne réponse
après je crois que tu vois dans le dans
le Texas ou l'arc ça je suis pas sûr qu'
a beaucoup de tram tu vois pour moi
c'est plus des des calèches avec des
fusiades à gauche à droite tu vois et
des et encore des des bandits le tram je
suis pas je pense que ce soit assez
développé je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de
pickup c'est possible le bon gros le TR
le bon gros
Tru sur le numéro 3 le numéro d'Alan
ierson
is bien vu non c'est ça c'est ça toon
Mark c'est un joueur qui a fait 3 ans du
coup avec les Houston
KERS qui était le compagnon le frère
d'arme de Marcus Saur qui joue
maintenant avec
Detroit c'était leur pitbull Bulldog
défensif et cette année il s'est dit je
vais kiffer je vais prendre l'argent et
le ballon et il a rejoint donc les ça
les thes de Eric msonman avec beaucoup
beaucoup de de transfuge on a parlé de
Calif battle on a pas parlé encore on
parler dans l'année de jeremah Davenport
euh et puis incontournable Trevon Brazil
à l'intérieur ancien de Missouri qui a
qui est depuis 2 ans àa malgré une BL
sur l'an dernier qui a écarté ce joueur
d'un l'OT tripic qui était attendu et
cette année comme je disais plus de
responsabilité bal en main il a voulu
montrer au staff NBA qui pouvait initier
du jeu qui pouvait qui pouvait remonter
la balle qui pouvait faire du pick and
roll qui pouvait pull up bon on n'est
pas hyper fan de ça
ça force principale c'est quand même
d'être un Sendy de très haute qualité on
est sur du 40 % à 3 points cette année
avec quatre prises par match donc un
volume qui est assez conséquent on est
sur des lancer franc alors cette année
pour l'instant il commence pas très bien
71 % mais c'est un garçon qui a plus de
80 % en carrière 18 points au global
donc je disais 1,6 79 kg euh 16 81 kg
pardon et qui pendant ces années à
Houston était toujours chargé de se
taper le meilleur porteur de balle
adverse donc vrai vrai gros rideau un
premier rideau sur le point of attack et
ça c'est très profitable en NB sur un
rôle de send alors justement vu que tu
commences par ses points forts et son
point fort on l'a bien compris c'est sa
défense est-ce qu'il est capable de
switcher parce que ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très valuable pour
une une équipe NBA ouais il F très bien
sur les petits parce qu'il va leur
donner des il va leur donner des des
lignes en fait euh c'est un joueur qui
va te dire tu vas aller dans ce sens-l
je que sur ta main gauche ou que sur ta
main droite et je vais te suivre il
bouge bien les pieds très puissants dans
le bas du corps pour encaisser les
contacts euh peu de faute des mains très
active aussi capable d'être très
agressif sur le ballon pour obliger le
joueur d'en face à à reprendre son
drible et euh puis sur des plus grands
comme il est déjà encore mature prêt euh
qu'il a des longs bras j'ai pas
l'envergure mesuré mais il a des longs
bras on peut aller défendre des trois
des petits quat donc ouais vraie switch
stabilité très bon joueur pour lutter à
travers les écrans donc loin du ballon
c'est pareil c'est une ten donc sur même
si ça switche pas il suit il agresse et
euh bon rebondeur aussi euh quelqu'un
qui va faire le back out bon second
rideau défensif vraimement il y a peu de
secteurs de jeu en défense où Tron ne va
pas être positif pour son équipe par
contre tu nous avvez parlé dans
l'épisode 1 de ndos que la défense
d'Arcana pour l'instant était assez
moyenne est-ce que lui collectivement il
s'y retrouve quand même dans le schéma
collectif en tout cas bah
individuellement euh il fait il fait
quand même des efforts après il est
moins impliqué parce que bah en attaque
il a il a beaucoup de ballons et
qu'effectivement collectivement c'est
c'est plus complexe et ils ont des
comment dire ils ont des des petits qui
vont charger des petits donc il se
tapent plus systématiquement le meilleur
porteur de bal adverse euh il y a un
freshman là qui s'appelle brokers donc
un vrai nom euh bah de de becc de
l'argonza tout simplement qui va faire
beaucoup de responsabilité dès qu'il
sort du banc et qui va toujours se taper
le le l'arrière donc euh ouais lui il a
un peu forcément ça le change hein quand
tu passes avec jest Walker avec Marcus
sassur et cetera et compagnie euh au
trip de Calif battle et Travon Brésil
qui se colore les cheveux c'est un autre
un autre délire quoi tu nous a parlé de
sa défense donc un très bon défenseur ce
soit sur l'homme mais aussi en non
porteur de balle euh qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire offensivement à part que comme
tu l'as dit très bien cette année il
essaie un peu de se montrer alors pour
le meilleur et pour le pire j'ai envie
de dire est-ce que tu peux nous parler
un peu de ses qualités offensives est-ce
qu'il a faire valoir au niveau d'dessus
bah oui ben on a commencé avec le tir à
3 points alors 40 % cette année il
progresse chaque année au niveau de la
mécanique c'est de plus en plus compact
et c'est de plus en plus rapide avec une
distance NBA près du panier alors c'est
que le début de saison hein mais il a 90
% de réussite près du cercle ce qui est
assez énorme avec euh 46 % de F rate ça
veut dire que le garçon près du panier
il rate pas grand-chose et en plus de ça
euh il provoque des fautes donc
là-dessus il met en avant ses qualités
athlétique et sa dominance euh physique
avec ses 4 ans de d'université et je te
disais sur pi and roll euh je suis pas
le plus grand fan de ça mais il faut
avouer que lorsqu'il va initier le jeu
qui va prendre du pullup midistance il
est efficace à 49 % sur le pullup
middistance donc vraiment des des
chiffres très élevés dans tous les
secteur du jeu
euh le point faible pour lui ça va être
le manque de de de variété dans le
drible euh pas capable vraiment de
changer de rythme euh sur sa main for
sur sa main faible pas capable de
vraiment changer de direction on est
plus pour moi dans sa projection sur un
joueur qui va euh attraper tirer et si
le défenseur monte trop saute dans la
fininte il peut aller finir près du
panier ou bien il va cut près du cercle
et va finir sachant qu'à Houston c'était
une une école de de jeu sans ballon où
les mecs arrêtaient pas de d'attaquer le
robot offensif et de cut dans tous les
sens donc il a ça il sait se placer il
comprend les défenses et il peut finir
donc moi je vais dire que cette année
c'est du bonus parce qu'il montre qu'il
peut sanctionner avec efficacité et
prendre un rôle plus important s'il y a
besoin dans une équipe où on lui donne
ça mais que ça son rôle NBA on l'a déjà
vu 3 ans en pendant 3 ans avant et
d'autant plus qu'il est dans une
conférence qui est quand même réputé
pour être compétitive he c'est la SC on
le rappelle euh donc il va y avoir des
gros match contre Alabama contre Mizou
contre tout ça donc forcément ça peut
aussi ça peut aussi aider à à faire
monter sa côte en en rencontrant des
adversaires d'un bon calibre euh Julien
tu l'as vu aussi trèon marque ouais je
l'ai vu et moi j'ai alors j'ai été très
surpris par la forme de son shoot tu tu
voulais poser une question pierre ah bah
justement ça ça m'intéresse c'est
exactement là où je voulais aller
c'était sur c'est un gaucher qu'est-ce
que tu peux me dire sur son tir comment
tu peux l'expliquer aux gens compliqué à
expliquer il est très très désaxé quoi
que je je sais pas si on dit ça en fait
hein c'est c'est vraiment très étrange
on a l'impression qu'il change de de
shoot tout le temps il est comment dire
il a ce pied Ceed qui est gauche très en
avant il a les épaules qui sont très
tournées et puis a ce bras qui se balade
un petit peu mais il est il est il reste
quand même très efficace quoi il peut
être très très efficace avec son shoot
c'est un peu déstabilisant à voir au
début surtout quand il finit les jambes
croisées quand il finit son son jum
shoot quoi donc c'est c'est très bizarre
on se demande si c'est pas si ça va
vraiment secourer et c'est un scourur en
fait enfin il arrive à secourer de façon
assez régulière en tout cas en NC pour
l'instant dans ce début d'année au tout
début il dans les premières années il
poussaiit tu sais c'était vraiment
quelque chose de très poussé et tu as
l'impression que le mec il a tout mis
dans la muscu et qu'il a tout contracté
et que vraiment genre c'est il se dit
vas-y je bloque tout et je lance et
c'est vrai que c'est plus efficace mais
c'est très très très peu académique moi
pour le décrire je sais pas si vous êtes
d'accord avec moi mais on a l'impression
que c'est un shoot toutqu du parc un peu
ça ouais clairement ais il y a un truc
un peu comme ça je sais pas com le
décrire autrement tellement c'est
atypique en fait donc j'espère que ça
vous donnera chers auditeurs l'envie
d'aller voir au moins à quoi ça
ressemble parce que c'est vrai que c'est
assez étonnant comme comme mécanique de
tir qu'est-ce que tu au lancer franc
aussi he ouais quand on c'est lancer
franc c'est assez bizarre même c'est
dans C FR sont bizarres mais moi j'aime
beaucoup les la variation de ses appuis
quand il attaque le panier je trouve
qu'il a un peu tout en magasin quand
même j'aime bien comme il peut allonger
partir en flotteur à PEL de pied et je
trouve que au contact au cercle il a
alors c'est peut-être parce qu'il a fait
de la muscu comme je dis je trouve qu'il
est il est assez correct en fait dans
dans cet exercice moi c'est surtout ça
90 % près du paniel 90 c'est ouais c'est
top ti ouais ouais et puis est ouais
très agressif et puis il a cette
variation dans dans son attaque du
panier quoi l'impression qu'il fait
jamais la même chose quoi alors souvent
il y a aussi un qui dit que souvent les
gauchiers ils ont vraiment qu'une
seulement est-ce que c'est aussi son cas
très bon marque alors je te laisse la
parole mais j'ai l'IM que en tout cas au
niveau du manement du ballon il a les
deux mains très faciles
ouais moi je les deux mains j'aime pas
son changement de main mais il peut
partir des deux mais je trouve ça voilà
je trouve que c'est vraiment un joueur
de d'attaque de clusot plus qu'un joueur
de d'initiation sur pit and roll et que
quand tu agresse son drible très vite ou
que tu vas lui mettre un premier contact
il va plus galérer il va transmettre
donc je crois pas trop en cette
projection qu'il a il est en train de
montrer mais c'est c'est du bonus et
plus tu peux faire tes gamme plus tu as
de chance de de montrer à des gens et de
peut-être séduire quelqu'un donc je
trouve ça très intéressant pour lui
après alors je sais pas si peut-être une
impression sur ce que j'ai vu de lui
mais j'ai l'impression qu'il y a aussi
quand même pas mal de tir àes distance
alors ça on sait que c'est un peu
réservé à une élite en NBA est-ce que ça
c'est projetable ou pas selon vous c'est
pas que c'est nouveau dans son jeu mais
encore une fois tu vois l'an dernier il
les avait pas ces ballons là euh c'était
Marcus saassœur et j'ai oublié son son
compè de de crime mais il a il avait pas
trop ces occasions là donc cette année
il nous montre ça et je trouve qu'il y a
dans les 40 % de réussite il y a
beaucoup de tu vois de de choses en
poussé de runneur de flotteur plus que
du du pullup sanctionné élévation donc
encore une fois on prend mais je vais
préférer le le voir aller au panier
faire du catch à TR points je pense pas
qu'il l'aura ça au niveau supérieur mais
voilà ça que s'il sait le faire c'est
qu'il peut étirer le jeu et faire des
choses correctes au niveau après il y a
un truc qu'on a pas mentionné donc il
fait 1,86 ça tu l'avais dit u 80 kg
capable de switcher en défense ça tu me
l'a très bien dit offensivement est-ce
qu'on l'imagine sur un sur un poste de
comboarde ou c'est un 2 3 ou un 2
exclusif ouais swingman je je le vois
bien euh sur les postes de 3 qui va se
taper le meilleur
porteur de balle arrière et lié adverse
dans un rôle alors c'est encore un
chouchou à moi mais qui peut ressembler
à ce que osayak Badi a maintenant même
si pour moi bad joue pas assez mais ayak
Badi fait en NBA dans un corps et un
rôle qui est assez similaire messieur
comment vous le projetez à moyen terme à
la fin de la saison là ça va en NBA ça
va ailleurs ça va en France ça va en
Chine dites-nous tout HUG
bon pour moi ça va NBS c'est ça va
s'acheter alors la draft on l'a pas dit
depuis qu'on a commencé les les
undererdgs mais elle est tellement
ouverte pour pas dire autre chose que on
parle là de mecs qui sont Underdogs qui
vont peut-être partir fin de premier
tour et on parlera peut-être de mecs
dans les f stars qu'on pensait peut-être
top 25 qui vont être second tour
undrafted donc ça ça peut très bien
séduire une fin de premier tour pour une
équipe très compétitive et pour moi
second tour quasi obligatoire est-ce que
tu HUG tu m'as parlé la fois dernière de
Calif battle est-ce que on a des Red
Flag un petit peu comme pour Calif ou
pas pour ce garçon non là-dessus j'ai
j'ai rien trouvé euh au niveau du
comportement c'est assez impeccable au
niveau de la famille c'est pas une
famille de basketteurs euh par contre
les parents sont très derrière donc ils
ont il y a trois enfants euh pour les
niveaux académiques donc eux ils veulent
que leurs enfants soient diplômés bon
benah voilà lui il a fait ses qu et très
sérieux très rigoureux ça c'est plutôt
bon signe aussi exactement Julien un
avis
sur moi je pense qu'il a sa chance ouais
il a sa
chance sil connaî en plus ce rôle s'il a
eu ce rôle là dans les années
[Musique]
d'avant de
gars et puis qu'il a parce
que ça évolu aussi c'est c'est un po qui
évolu un rôle qui évolue en tout cas
donc ouais avec tout ce qui montre c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui va tester qui va
être testé assez d'accord aussi on
l'imagine
assez facilement on va dire dans sur un
second tour à minima quand même parce
que quelqu'un qui défend déjà c'est ça
s'achète et puis si en plus de ça il
continue à être à droit à trois points
il y a pas de raison que une équipe NBA
ne s'intéresse pas à lui je pense qu'on
a fait le tour sur Tréon marque on va
passer sur un joueur qui est un petit
peu plus compliqué à prononcer surtout
pour moi c'est lise Dixon war de C rose
state Julien parle-nous de ce garçon
qu'on appellera peut-être par convenance
si vous voulez bien
RDW c'est peut-être plus facile à dire
en tout cas pour moi donc voilà je
préviens un peu président
présidented
St alors il est de Diego stage c'est pas
s pros c'est s Diego c'est un purure
Californien euh qui était donc qui est
sorti je crois 4 étoiles du lycée alors
il a un début en NC qu' qu' l'accélère
moi je suis pas très très au courant de
tout ça mais en fait il commence au deè
semestre à USC il commence à
USC une des équipes phare de la pctel
enfin phare connu de la pctel en de Los
Angeles qui reste de la ce qui reste de
la p alors on en parlera plus tard parce
que là il en reste encore un peu c'est
l'année prochaine où c'est l'explosion
euh et donc il fait 3 ans à USI ou
peut-être que 2 ans et demi si pu
commence au 2è semestre dans un rôle de
6e homme qui l'a mis à profit puisquil
finit l'année dernière meilleur 6e homme
de de la
conférence donc 1,96 95 kg c'est un
un ailiier un arrière ailier combo un
arrière ailier quoi ouais porté sur la
défense et le shoot à 3 points en C
shoot pendant pendant ces années d' et
ce qui est assez intéressant est-ce
qu'on moi en tout cas ce que je vais su
cette année c'est qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire cette année avec San Diego St vu
qu'il a plus de de liberté au niveau
offensif il est plus utilisé plus
régulièrement parce que ces années à Los
Angeles é un petit peu compliqué qui est
au niveau du temps de jeu qui varia
beaucoup et là il apparemment V début
d'année il est il est plus posé il a
plus un un temps de jeu qui qui se
retrouve et on lui on lui offre la
possibilité de plus de plus de
participer au scoring donc euh ces
forces ben c'est le c'est le shoot quoi
essentiellement le le shoot à à 3 points
en cating shoot et euh et une grosse
défense par ailleurs alors
cette année moi je t'avoue sur les
premiers matchs que j'ai vu c'est c'est
moins évident alors je t'envoyé un match
je sais pas si tu l'as vu et Pierre je
pas si vous l'avez vu tous les deux
celui de Miami où ils sont éliminé avec
Us March mades en
2022 yes non vous avez fait vos devoir
c'est bien les gars yes et là et là
c'était un petit peu je trouve que
c'était ça pour moi ça marquait vraiment
ce qu'il était quoi grosse grosse
présence défensive et assez fiable au
niveau du j à trois points est capable
comme ça de avec ses deux qualités
d'apporter très fort à à l'équipe et et
il les remet dedans quoi même s'il perd
donc là tu nous as fait un peu le profil
d'un d'un streendy est-ce qu'il est
capable de faire autre chose ou à la
marge pour moi c'est c'est comme je te
dis je vais regarder mais ça me semble
un peu compliqué il est il m'a
l'air il est assez
euh il est pour l'instant il est en
dedans je trouve dans dans le rôle qu'
qu'on pourrait lui donner cette année de
d'initiateur il est parfois mais c'est
pas c'est pas pour l'instant c'est pas
ce qu'on c'est pas encore ça voilà par
contre il a des gestes il a ses flash il
fait des passes avec une main avec deux
mains rebond il a il a la panoplie mais
il s'en sert pas beaucoup alors ce que
j'avais lu moi je l'ai pas vu au lycée
faut être honnête et par contre ce que
j'avais lu sur lui c'est que il a avait
euh il était projeté comme
possible possible initiateur d'attaque
après je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
sont projeté comme ça à fin de
lycée possible scoreur plus initiateur
il l'a pas montré dans ses années USI et
je pense que il va rester dans ce rôle
plutôt de de scoreur de boutcha même
s'il est capable de d'attraper le ballon
en cut d'aller vers le panier de
délivrer des passes euh par contre voir
initier du pick and R ENF qu'est-ce que
tu mettrais comme faiblesse à corriger
pour lui pour espérer aller plus haut
alors je pense qu'il y a une faiblesse
qui est intrinsèque qui va pas haut en
fait
ouais euh quand il attaque le CERC c'est
pas très très aérien euh c'est pas très
rapide et et il a pas il a pas cette
aisance quoi c'est pas un gars qui va
traverser le le terrain à tout alure et
claquer un dunk en attaque c'est pas ça
et euh il est plus c'est c'est plus un
joueur de de jeu demi-terrain quoi donc
ça je pense que c'est c'est c'est une
faiblesse intrinsèque chez lui et qui je
vois pas comment tu peux régler ça il y
AA jamais très haut très vite voilà HM
et ça limite en fait du coup ça limite
la le spectre offensif qu'il pourrait
avoir
ouais est-ce que dans dans la mécanique
enin moi il y a ça va peut-être sauter
au visage mais peut-être pas pour tout
le monde dans la mécanique qui te fait
penser à un joueur en particulier alors
ouais mais moi tu sais que je suis
complètement nul en comparaison l'ann
derniè trouvé à MRE reprise et tu veux
que j'envoie quelqu'un comme ça moi il
fait penser à à
Burks mince qu'est-ce que c'est son
prénom Alex BKS tu vois ce ce shoot très
fluide avec ce ce coup de poignet à la
fin là il je pense que que c'est un gars
qui a des grandes mains
euh on le voit dans les interviews là
quand il se frotte le monton là je pense
c'est un gars qui a des assez grandes
mains et du coup il y a cette souplesse
dans la main quoi tu vois les shoterurs
ave des grandes tabuches là il me fait
penser à lui à B parce que y a cette
fluidité dans le je fais une parenthèse
à chaque fois qu'il finit son tir avec
le truc j'ai l'impression qu'il va
lâcher du selleim que c'est une
provocation c'est vraiment un fouetté à
la fin il reste posé la main en avant en
mode vraiment drop le S ou je vois quand
tu veux parler ouais et ben HUG
qu'est-ce que tu en as vu est-ce que tu
l'as vu déjà et qu'est-ce que tu en as
pensé de r dick and waters yes je l'ai
regardé un un bon petit tank il est il
est pas enfin il fait 1 M96 et puis il a
il assez stock
euh bien puissant moi j'aime bien un bon
un bon buffle euh qui pour faire la
parenthèse peut rappeler un peu Admiral
Scofield
qui qui est une légende du podcast mais
dans le dans le dans le morphotype dans
le build j'aime bien et je me suis du
coup pas mal renseigné comme je savais
que Julien allait plus maîtriser le jeu
sur un petit peu l'entourage la famille
du garçon et tout et ce que j'ai bien
aimé c'est que dans son choix de de fac
il a pris une université qui a fait des
bons résultats et il a refusé des des
Niles alors je sais pas comment ils
disent des n tu vois enfin moi il a
refusé la moulaga pour pour faire
simplement NCA parce que enfin pour
prioriser plutôt un programme avec des
des bons résultat académique avec un
coach qui l'entour bien et c'est la
famille était très contente de ce
choix-là donc ils ont dit non merci pour
les grosses sommes d'argent que allit
proposé et ils sont pris ouais Texas
aussi et ils ont pris plutôt une comment
dire une éducation comme il disait
là-bas euh tu rejoins aussi Julien sur
les faiblesses sur le le côté athlétique
du du joueur
tu en vois d'autres ouais quand tu vois
la masse à soulever c'est normal hein il
est bien il est bien développé après je
pense que cette puissance au sol va
pouvoir lui servir quand même en NBA
parce qu'on va
pas lui demander de faire énormément de
choses dans sa qualité verticale
offensivement par contre défensivement
je le vois bien du coup se farcir des
des gros ailiers peut-être des fois
défendre plus grand que lui tout en
gardant de la POV avec du spacing donc
je suis pas non plus hyper inquiet
là-dessus HUG nous fait la passe
décisive Julien sur la sur la projection
est-ce qu'on arrive à le projeter au
niveau supérieur ce garçon ou pas du
coup je pense qu'il a il a deux
qualités qui peuvent intéresser voilà
c'est un ailiier il défend et il défend
pas que du un contre un il est il aide
beaucoup en défense of ball il est
concentré il boxe donc au niveau
défensif il est assez
complet et puis il shoot il a shot il a
mis il est à 100 % au lancé front depuis
le début d'année bon c'est une anomalie
he c'est ça va s'arrêter il y a 5 C
matchs euh voilà mais c'est un gars qui
apporte une une stabilité enfin qui a un
shoot stable donc c'est deux c'est c'est
deux qualités pour un ailiier qui qui
sont assez costaud donc on peut
l'attendre après voilà HUG a parlé de
cette draft euh c'est une drôle de draft
bon si on l'attend de toute façon ce
sera au second tour je c'est c'est c'est
sûr et ce sera en bas non qu'est-ce que
tu en penses tu toi tu es plus
spécialiste que moi pour projeter comme
ça
spécialiste je sais pas mais mais oui
second tour et c'est pas non plus parce
que là on a raison d'en parler comme il
fait des belles States et qui a un beau
volume de tir à TR points il est 4e
année donc il peut en avoir une 5e c'est
pas impossible qu'il fasse une qu'il
fasse une 5e année celle d'après moi je
vais attendre de voir vraiment le le tir
s'il peut stabiliser sur toute une année
avec CIN prises par match au moins 43 %.
parce que là il a quasi doublé son
nombre de tir tentés à 3 points par
rapport à l'an dernier l'an dernier il
fait pas une grosse saison alors
contexte particulier FC et le CPL C
c'était assez désastreux entre Boogie et
lis qui passe son temps à déclencher Dr
piterson la fatiguable mais il était à
29 % l'an dernier donc ouais si il y a
une blessure aussi il y a une blessure
pendant l'année ah oui effectivement il
joue que 29 et ouais ouais avec un temps
de jeu voilà que ouais faut pas falloir
voir cette
année un truc qu'on a peut-être pas
mentionné c'est que pour un joueur
senior il reste relativement jeune c'est
un 2002 ça effectivement dans l'optique
de faire une 5e année ça pourrait se
tenir aussi quoi c'est qu'il arriverait
pas complètement à la draft à à 25 ans
même si il y allait que que que l'année
prochaine donc c'est vrai que c'est une
donnée peut-être à prendre en compte
aussi moi pour revenir sur ma
comparaison je trouvais que dans la
technique de tir en tout cas moi il me
faisait beaucoup penser à à Mosé smoie
le joueur maintenant de Golden
State même dans le physique il y a un
côté un peu comme ça aussi tentaculaire
aussi très très long ouais assez long et
puis costaud quand même mine de rien
parce que 95 kg pour un mec 96 on est
déjà costaud he donc donc voilà est-ce
que on a des choses N a rajouté sur
notre ami
RDW et pourquoi est-ce qu'il a mis un
t-shirt cette année quoi qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce t-shirt flottant quoi moi
c'est je je suis demandais mais
qu'est-ce que c'est enfin des vrais
sujets merci Julien ben oui et puis
voilà mais c'est puis dernière chose
c'est que sans degost c'est quand même
une fac qui a sorti quelques joueurs
assez sympathique hein avec des grandes
mains quoi il y a quand même kawai s de
de la fac alors bon ça remonte un petit
peu mais euh c'est la la la Mountain we
conférence c'est celle de de San dieago
Steed c'est c'est une c'est une
conférence qui sort des joueurs NBA
alors c'est pas forcément des joueurs
que haai mais il sort des joueurs
intéressants donc c'est un c'est
peut-être aussi ce qui l'a poussé à
aller là-bas
et donc ouais moi je vais regarder en
tout cas je va regarder je suis très
curieux de son année là et du coup tu
fais un big up au papa d'an monsieur
Guillou monsieur Guillou senior non qui
euh qui a fait du soccer c'est ça San
Diego state ouais ouais c'est ça et ben
voilà big up Mister Guillou bah du coup
on en profite aussi pour saluer Alan en
espérant qu'il a emporté avec lui sa
fameuse étagère massive aux USA en tout
cas on l'embrasse on pense fort à lui et
puis de toute façon on risque encore de
parler de de Santa Clara cette année
apparemment on est bien sûr sur le
dossier vous inquiétez pas puis toujours
en contact avec Alan évidemment aussi
messieur est-ce qu'on a fini avec notre
ami en trois lettres
RDW on ne prononcera plus le nom avec
wiiziz RI pour les
intimes on est bon ouais je crois que
c'est bon ouais c'est bon et ben ainsi
va se finir Underdogs numéro 2 messieur
j'étais très content de pouvoir en
discuter avec vous et puis j'ai très
hâte de vous retrouver pour une
prochaine émission on évoquera d'autres
prospects plus ou moins sombres on
continue dans cette veine là on vous dit
à très vite sur les podcast envergure
évidemment si vous voulez nous contacter
pour x ou y raison n'hésitez pas sur
Twitter enfin x comme on dit maintenant
et puis surtout le plus important prenez
soin de vous à bientôt bye
[Musique]
bye